bis ich in rente gehen kann vergeht
gefüllt noch eine ewigkeit genauer
gesagt 40 jahre dann bin ich nämlich 67
und trotzdem manches zu dem thema geht
dann doch nicht so spurlos an mir vorbei
gerade sehr wahrscheinlich dass viele in
ihrer generation die jetzt heute mitte
20 sind erst mit 70 oder vielleicht 75
damit 80 in rente gehen experten gehen
davon aus dass unser jetziges
rentensystem bald versagt und für meine
generation viel zu wenig übrig bleibt
als ich anfang 20 mit 20 wollten wir das
durchgerechnet haben ja so würdig war
ich war mir klar auf die gesetzliche
rente kann ich wirklich gerade um die
ecke zwischen 20 und 30 ist und er denkt
man mutig wie vor wichtig nicht
unendlich lange zeit um
die neue regierung will die rente
deswegen stärken und zwar mit
investitionen am kapitalmarkt die antl
will die sogenannte aktien rente
einführen meine sorge ist wenn der staat
anfängt mit ein teil der rente zu zocken
das dann natürlich die unsicherheit
immer größer wird wenn sich die börsen
negativ entwickeln werden einfach manche
menschen dann weniger rente kriegen ich
will wissen verzockt oder wertet die
ampel unsere rente darin geht es jetzt
[Musik]
um zu verstehen warum es dringend eine
rentenreform braucht habe ich mir erst
mal einen überblick über unser jetziges
system verschafft warum braucht es eine
rentenreform und seit enden system
basiert auf drei säulen die gesetzliche
rentenversicherung der betriebliche und
die private altersvorsorge die
gesetzliche rentenversicherung ist die
stärkste säule oder sollte es sein als
sozialversicherungspflichtige
arbeitnehmer in zeit man selbst und der
arbeitgeber in die rentenkasse ein der
staat gibt geld dazu und die jetzigen
rentner innen bekommen aus diesem topf
ihre rente das heißt die jüngeren
finanzieren die rente der alten das ist
das sogenannte
umlageverfahren auch bekannt als
generationenvertrag aktuell sieht es für
meine generation so aus dass wir ab dem
67 lebensjahr in rente gehen können und
dann 48 prozent des letzten gehalts aus
der gesetzlichen rentenkasse bekommen
sollen denn genau dieser
generationenvertrag der es in gefahr
denn es gibt immer weniger junge
menschen die für die vielen rentner
innen 1 1 dazu kommt die lebenserwartung
steigt also menschen sind länger auf
ihre rente angewiesen schon jetzt lässt
sich absehen dass dieses system
wahrscheinlich bald kollabiert 1962 ging
man davon aus dass sechs beitragszahlern
eine rentnerin finanzieren
2050 werden es 1,3 beitragszahler pro
rentnerin seien die möglichen düsteren
folgen altersarmut und ein rentner leben
am existenzminimum
obwohl man 40 jahre lang gearbeitet und
in die rentenkasse eingezahlt hat damit
das nicht passiert sagen einige experten
wir werden weniger rente bekommen wir
müssen jetzt schon mehr einzahlen oder
aber länger arbeiten und länger
einzahlen der wissenschaftliche beirat
des wirtschaftsministeriums schlägt zum
beispiel vor dass wir das
renteneintrittsalter um ein jahr erhöhen
und zwar ab 2042 von 67 auf 68 als grund
gibt das gremium an das wir ja auch
länger leben also die lebenserwartung ja
aufsteigt und wer länger lebt der saal
auch länger arbeiten wissenschaftler
innen des instituts der deutschen
wirtschaft ziehen noch drastischere
konsequenzen
sie befürworten die rente ab 70 jetzt
könnte man denken die neue regierung die
folgt den empfehlungen der expertinnen
tut sie aber nicht sie will dass es bei
der rente ab 67 bleibt sie schreibt im
koalitionsvertrag
es wird keine rentenkürzungen und keine
anhebung des gesetzlichen
renteneintrittsalter geben wie will die
ampel das schaffen die koalition hat
sich vorgenommen und ich lese das jetzt
ab weil es klingt ein bisschen
kompliziert in eine teilweise
kapitaldeckung der gesetzlichen
rentenversicherung einzusteigen was
bedeuteten dass ein teil der
eingezahlten rentenbeiträge soll am
kapitalmarkt angelegt statt direkt an
die jetzigen rentner innen weitergegeben
zu werden es soll ein forum geben der
von einer unabhängigen
öffentlich-rechtlichen stelle verwaltet
wird und global anlegt und die deutsche
rentenversicherung soll auch ihre
reserven in aktienfonds anlegen dürfen
zu dieser reform will die ampel zehn
milliarden euro bereitstellen das ziel
das rentenniveau halten und das
renteneintrittsalter sichern für die
einen klingt das vernünftig für die
anderen eher riskant in schweden gibt es
dieses modell schon die menschen dort
seien 2,5 prozent ihres monatlichen
bruttogehalt in einen aktienfonds in
einem privaten oder in einen staatlichen
und das funktioniert in den vergangenen
zehn jahren schaffte der staatliche
fonds eine durchschnittliche jährliche
rendite von mehr als 14 prozent
ich frage mich kann das auch in
deutschland funktionieren oder ist das
zockerei mit unserer agenda
[Musik]
der alternative wäre den steuerzuschuss
von jahr zu jahr zu erhöhen und die
frage ist wo soll das steuergeld herum
insofern war das klar dass der status
quo nur
rentenversicherungsbeiträge und
steuerzuschuss alleine nicht ausreichen
wird und dir da gerne eine langfristige
komponente rhein haben wollen und
deswegen der blick auf globaler
aktienmärkte sozusagen der richtige ist
dennis bonn hilft was für die fdp bei
den koalitionsverhandlungen zu dem thema
dabei er sagt langfristige investitionen
am kapitalmarkt sind vielversprechend
das ist also keine zockerei er sagt aber
auch das rentenproblem sei damit längst
nicht gelöst wir reden jetzt von vier
jahren regierungszeit und bei ihnen
haben wir jetzt noch fast 40 jahre zeit
bis sie in die wohlverdiente rente gehen
werden da passiert noch so viel in
deutschland dass das tatsache jeder der
sich jetzt hinstellt und ihnen und mir
verspricht die rente so 100 prozent
sicher das es sowas von unseriös wir
können jetzt nur dafür sorge tragen dass
das dass die wahrscheinlichkeit dass das
kommen wird größer wird und je mehr man
sich breiter aufstellt und das was wir
tun ist ja sich finanziell breiter
aufstellen desto besser ist es was
haltet ihr von den rentenplänen der
neuen regierung schreibt uns das mal
unten in die kommentare ich habe noch
zwei expertinnen zu ihrer meinung
gefragt der eine sagt die aktien rente
ist prinzipiell eine gute idee aber
meiner ansicht nach gut hier viel zu
wenig die reform die hier vorgesehen die
will das problem nicht lösen die
anbieter sagt die pflichten der aktien
rente ist der falsche ansatz meine sorge
ist wenn der staat anfängt mit ein teil
der rente zu zocken das dann natürlich
die unsicherheit immer größer wird wenn
sich die börsen negativ entwickeln
werden einfach manche menschen dann
weniger rente kriegen der ökonom ralf
rascher findet unser rentensystem
braucht noch mehr reformen als nur die
aktion rente der vorschlag der aktion
rente ist gut weil das was menschen in
die gesetzliche rente einzahlen da geben
sich
vermehrt also eine rendite
erwirtschaftet aber es reicht nicht die
drei wichtigsten stellschrauben nicht
adressiert sind die drei wichtigsten
stellschrauben sind das
renteneintrittsalter das eigentlich an
die lebenserwartung gekoppelt werden
muss das zweite ist dass mehr menschen
gute arbeit haben mit guten löwen und
das dritte ist dass wir nach wie vor ein
rentensystem haben das von unten nach
oben von einzureichen und verteilt also
für gerade für menschen mit ihren
lebenseinkommen vorn und hinten nicht
reicht und solange diese probleme nicht
adressiert werden wird man dass die
gesetzliche rente in deutschland nicht
wirklich auf nachhaltige füße stellen
verena bentele steht dem größten
sozialverband in deutschland vor und der
setzt sich für einen starken sozialstaat
ein das problem ist ich ebensee ist ganz
klar der staat muss dann eben auch alle
schwankungen natürlich mitmachen wenn
die börse runter geht muss man den
menschen vielleicht sagen sorry du
kriegst jetzt 50 oder 100 euro weniger
rente für jemand mit wenig rente sind 50
oder 100 euro richtig viel zweites
problem ist aber auch dass der staat
natürlich dann zum zocker wird am
kapitalmarkt und natürlich auch in
produkte anlegen muss die vielleicht
eben nicht nachhaltig sind und damit
lassen wir dann eben andere dafür zahlen
dass wir eine gute rendite machen
weltweit und das kann eben auch nicht
sein der sozialverband plädiert dafür
das jetzige umlagesystem zu stärken und
schlägt vor dass andere erwerbstätige
auch beamte politiker in und
selbstständige in eine gemeinsame
rentenkasse einzahlen so könne es für
alle eine gerechte rente geben also die
neue regierung hat nicht vor auf die
wissenschaftler im zuhören die meinen
wir müssten länger arbeiten und länger
einzahlen stattdessen will sie mit
unserer rente an den kapitalmarkt und
die dort familien gerettet ist die rente
für meine generation damit aber noch
nicht es ist längst nicht klar ob die
aktien rente in der geplanten form
erfolg haben wird wenn wir dann
tatsächlich einmal in rente gehen und
was dann noch übrig ist es bleibt uns
also weiter nichts anderes übrig als
auch selbst vorzusorgen
erinnert ihr euch an die drei sollen vom
anfang die private vorsorge dies ja eine
davon und die wird bei diesen unsicheren
aussichten wohl immer bedeutsamer weil
sich aber nicht jede und jeder immer
leisten kann geld zurückzulegen habe ich
noch mit thomas von finanzfluss
gesprochen den kennt ihr vielleicht der
macht hier auf youtube ja viele videos
zum thema geld und sparten er sagt in
die frage die sich dann ist eigentlich
nicht habe ich ein großes budget oder
habe ich ein kleines budget sondern die
frage die sich da ist eigentlich bin ich
ein bisschen also kann ich mit
schwankungen am kapitalmarkt umgehend
schwankungen anders ausgedrückt sind
wichtig ein risiko er findet jungen
menschen haben beim geldanlegen außerdem
zwei große vorteil weil man die zeit
die kann man optimieren indem man so
schnell wie möglich angepackt und von
jungen menschen gesprochen das bedeutet
wenn ich jung bin habe ich noch sehr
lange andere anlage zeit dass man
möglichst lange so klagt gesprochen für
mich arbeiten und das zweite ist das was
ich auf die seite legen sparer hat daran
kann ich auch arbeiten natürlich auch
optieren ob und wie ihr euer geld anlegt
das entscheidet er natürlich selbst wenn
er jetzt aber lust habt euch mit dem
thema altersvorsorge zu beschäftigen
dann empfehle ich euch dieses video hier
meine kollegin anna hat sich um ihre
altersvorsorge nämlich schon gekümmert
und wenn euch dieses video gefallen hat
dann lasst doch gerne ein leichter
[Musik]